hello and welcome to this video as a bit
of sleet start here but okay playin to
ski man good white again many white
summer and so ski man what are you up to
so when transposing to a symmetrical
here
yeah I'm getting some quick progress on
the queenside but he's playing in the
center let's see how it works out not
really am a line that has studied all
that much when I was compiling my my
video series down yeah this looks a
little bit off here for me actually
Knight to c3 oops my development looks
bad well my that didn't go all that well
check hmm I don't know what went wrong
way out I have no idea pretty pretty
weird position here yeah how do I get
this sorted maybe King up to G to my
night is still not doing anything at all
wow really I did that I didn't expect at
all
hmm i don't think that you for is
happening all that quickly and will seem
check so you want to go g5 or something
like that I mean possibly possible this
stuff looks weird maybe
where g 5 is possible definitely now in
some some form I know maybe you for
coming so an adapter and get this Bishop
out of it okay so i can actually take
now here right I like look at six or
something no let's take first
off the cream trade I think I'm okay so
i'm not sure that this house him so much
27 is interesting try and also for air
for i will go clean be five after that
movie goes for it hmm so i can actually
take on bucetinha there is no particular
reason why I shouldn't so I'm taking
ok so I've won this beep on check but
I'm not all that active yeah of course
this is something that I did not
anticipate so that's that's very
annoying actually how to do that having
ham taken here jack maybe you could have
checked you actually g5 really like a
jiff jiff all d4 he actually a default
Quincy tune yes Quincy to all the time
it's the problem
still so not at all easy
yeah it's difficult it's difficult to
get this stuff sorted out
hey time warning really difficult very
difficult to play for a win
so rookie six check check check check
wow I will say was tough getting out of
that weird position check check check
check black resins down there i miss
played that opening quite terribly mmm
yeah the interesting plan there with
with e six and stuff maybe d5 sorry
maybe maybe I have to handle d5 somehow
might have three or something the
sisters doesn't seem all that good right
my development is bad the ID I'm just a
terrible change at completely miss play
dead opening I don't think that f5 is
that good I am I I think if you just
place with pieces you should be fine
like between the computer wants to go
into the 626 roop t8 stuff like that
check and here this is my Kangol g5 he
could have done that and this really i
can go here with one what kind of
position is that it was a totally rotten
situation and i even here may I grabbed
it turn and still not easy at all check
yeah check he definitely has enough
therefore for the porn I was actually
thinking check it Queens it too is an
option here check now if I do this after
Bishop t4 i'm here i'm in an eternal pin
I'm not ever moving again so i probably
have to play him and this looks pretty
awful like this Wow hey I wasn't
extremely extremely lucky win can I can
I not do this Luke v8 what wow wow check
and I'm getting mated here oh my god why
what a shocker okay he didn't didn't see
it and now the aid again wins for loopy
to Jeremy no chance that it was just
like extremely lucky in this game okay
well thanks for watching